weapon progression is a core staple of
Call of Duty multiplayer an infinite
warfare continues to build on this
philosophy by offering more weapon
options than ever before once players
unlock a base weapon they'll be able to
get prototypes of that weapon through
the all-new crafting system prototypes
come in for rarity levels common rare
legendary and epic each with their own
combination of perks the legendary and
epic versions have the most sought-after
perks getting players new ways to
compete one such perk will award the
player with a tactical nuke following a
25 player kill streak for the first time
ever in a call of duty game infinite
warfare introduces crafting a new
addition to the weapon progression
system crafting allows players the
freedom to get the best prototypes that
fit their play style using salvaged the
in-game crafting currency salvaged can
be earned in a variety of ways so the
more you play the more prototypes you
can craft with such a diverse arsenal at
their disposal players have more
opportunities than ever before to
acquire the best weapons to fit their
play style get your hands on infinite
warfare all new weapon progression
system including prototypes and crafting
in the call of duty infinite warfare of
data
you
you